I've been doing a lot of improv lately.
And for those of you who don't know what improv is,
Improv is when a bunch of people go on stage
with no idea what they're going to perform
and they perform.
One of the most imperative rules of improv is
to say "yes and."
And that basically means you have to agree
to the circumstances set forth in the scene
and add to them.
So if someone says:
"Mom, I really want to get another cat."
You shouldn't say:
"I'm not your wife.  I'm your mom.
And if by cat you mean vagina, then I want a divorce!"
Now, what does that have to do with you and me?
Well, it has forced me to realize
exactly how often I say "no" my real life.
"Do you want to make love tonight?"
Uh, no.
I say no without even using the word no.
Hey!  Do you want to go camping this weekend?
I've got a bunch of work/Netflix to do/watch so...
I say no out of fear.
Hey, Anna?
Hm?
I've got an open slot on my comedy show
if you want to do some Stand-up (comedy) next weekend.
Ahhhhhh!
Thanks though.
I say no because I'm just too lazy.
Are you sure you don't want to make love?
No.
It's been many moons.
No I'm good.
I'm good.  I'm solid.
So something that I really want to start working on
is to stop saying no and start saying yes.
Because I started to think about all the
experiences that I would have had
if I had not said no.
And I'm not disillusioned, like I'm sure
if I said yes to all the experiences
some of them would be "meh" and some of them
would be downright terrible.
But at least I would have had a really good story.
And experienced more of life.
So Brad and I actually host a monthly live show
called the "Last Comedy Show" at Nerdmelt.
And at the last show I did stand-up (comedy)
as my Japanese character.
And after the show I usually do like a little meet-and-greet
and someone asked me to please do
the Japanese character the next time I have to do an ad
because she is missed.
So, here it is.
*clears through*
Thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring today's episode!
You can go to Squarespace.com
and start building your website today!
Squarespace has easy to use tools
everything is super intuitive!
Designs are all professional!
No coding required.
It's only eight dollars a month, so cheap!
Or you can get a free trial with no credit card down.
You can go to Squarespace and use offer code "Anna"
For 10% off.
Squarespace, build it beautiful.
Build it, Japanese.
I just spit all over the place.
(Brad Off-Camera) That was great.  I would use that one.
Okay.  Whew!
(Brad Off-Camera) Cut it?